así que está muy buenos días
efectivamente por un lado ya está
confirmado ese asiento en la cámara alta
por parte de raphael warnock el el
candidato demócrata con el 56% y luego
frente al 49,4 por ciento de qué ley lo
fer pero ahora la contienda está entre
jon o soft y david verdú el demócrata
contra el republicano de hecho el centro
de investigación es edison que están
monitoreando ese escrutinio que ahora
mismo está al 98 por ciento el candidato
demócrata estaría liderando el recuento
de votos con el 50,2 por ciento sin
embargo tanto la campaña demócrata como
la republicana son muy cautelosos o
porque dicen que hasta que no se cuente
hasta el último voto y no se pueda
confirmar el que efectivamente uno u
otro candidato ha ganado no podrán
celebrar la victoria aliviana anthony
cuéntenos ahora en caso de ganar los dos
democrátas las dos plazas quiero decir
que representaría esto para la
presidencia de joe biden
sí es importante remarcar que los
demócratas necesitan ganar los dos
escaños que actualmente poseen los
republicanos mientras que el partido
republicano solo necesitaba un
asegurarse un escaño para liderar la
cámara alta sí
qué significa eso básicamente que si los
republicanos lideran el senado de eeuu
podrían bloquear automáticamente la
agenda prevista del nuevo gobierno de
joe biden eso pasaría por ejemplo en
anular la reforma migratoria de la que
se comprometió el entonces candidato by
den a presentar durante los primeros 100
días de su gobierno y luego también
incluso anular el obama que es la
reforma sanitaria que tanta polémica ha
causado en el país